n-c-double-a tournament has really been
taking a you know obviously all of our
attention but they're still MBA news
going on and knowing other than to talk
about that news is the athletics in your
NBA Ryder Santa mimic joining the show
and and Sam what does the NBA do in
these you know a couple days while the
NCAA tournament is going on like the
Thursday through Sunday in terms of just
be the spotlight Kurt yeah in terms of
spotlight Sam yeah I mean I think it
takes a backseat you know I mean for one
it's always fun for me to see the
players themselves within the NBA right
kind of you get reminded that you know
these guys all have stories of their own
the vast majority of them you know we're
playing in March Madness at some point
and so you might have like a random you
know he'd Knicks game on a Friday and
guys in that locker room
they're kind of glued to that TV up
until tip-off time trying to watch you
know whichever squad they came from and
it's it's refreshing in that sense for
me because you know a they kind of look
like fans like the rest of us in that
regard and then you know just kind of
shows you their passion for the game and
how they haven't lost that but it's a
fun time of year for sure you know Sam
you know always at this time of year
especially when you have some
performances and we've said it before
SIA and watch starts later today at 7:10
p.m. Eastern Time as Duke plays North
Dakota State but I think we will get the
conversation as always the elimination
of the one-and-done possibly depending
on some other performance in this
tournament is that still getting the the
conversation around the NBA at some
point that they want and done rule will
be done with oh yeah for sure I mean the
formal proposal has been submitted it
seems at this point like a likely
foregone conclusion and you know it's
Adam Silver has ramped that thing up and
in his discussions and publicly he's
certainly ramped it up in his you know
more importantly in the substantive
discussions with the Players Union
privately with Michelle Roberts you know
their executive director he talked about
it recently at the Sloan conference in
Boston and was pretty candid about how
that's you know the train is heading
pretty pretty kind of hot and heavy down
those tracks and so I think you know
kind of what we talked about at the top
here
is the days of that dynamic are probably
nearing an end the athletic senior NBA
rider say I'm a meeting the Rich Eisen
show Kirk Morrison here filling in for
rich before the tournament started Zion
Williamson was kind of the consensus
number one overall pick but all of a
sudden job my rent has this performance
last night and you wake up this morning
Sam and it's like people are like wait
wait wait
could this be the number one overall
pick in the NBA Draft well how much have
you seen of john ruetten
and what are you hearing from NBA
executives about where he could possibly
land I mean admittedly I'm not too great
on I'm in a no job game and I saw what
he did last night
I think Zions got that thing locked up
you know what I mean I think you could
certainly have two discussions here
where jaw is going to be perceived as
you know every bit the elite prospect
you know and kind of in that rarefied
air as ion it feels right now and things
can change by the time draft night comes
around you know once it's always a
little silly but once these draft
workouts happen and different subplots
might come to the surface things of that
nature then maybe things shuffle around
again but those two guys are head and
shoulders above with you know a pretty
wide chasm between them of the rest of
the field
you know Samuel is a good week of
basketball obviously we're still buzzing
over that 76ers and Celtics game the
other day but then I look in the Western
Conference and it's four teams right now
that all have the same record Oklahoma
City San Antonio Utah and the LA
Clippers all with a record of 42 and 30
how do you see this thing playing out
and could you possibly see these teams
kind of jockeying a little bit about who
to escape in the first round possibly
yeah hundred percent I can't remember a
year Kirk where it was this loaded in
the bottom four it's funny because I'm
still living near Sacramento and seeking
friends in that neck of the woods we're
hoping to get in and it's just
incredible how you know they've had a
good year but now that gaps because
they're in nights that they don't have a
prayer anymore of getting into the group
that you talked about but the idea that
you can be eight one day and fit the
next is pretty unique at this point of
the season and the Jocelin is going to
be real because you know warriors
Denver being at the top of that group
you know you don't want to see them I
think that you know honestly Houston
unofficially is in that group so you
know if there's jostling to be had I
think it's you know just trying to avoid
those top three and see what you can do
from there but you know it should be fun
down the stretch and how do we look at
the the Eastern Conference now because
look Indiana's at four we saw the Sixers
at three that series against or the game
against Boston like I mentioned the
other day when you look at this Eastern
Conference playoff especially without
LeBron James this year is it still that
top-heavy for teams and just the bottom
four is not as strong as we would say
the West
yeah for sure I've been loving these
inside of things at the top like you
said I mean you know that really boss
ting game was big to Toronto Milwaukee
matchups I I told somebody yesterday I
said the fun thing about the second
round in the East is gonna be that it's
you know most likely is gonna feel like
two Conference Finals at the same time
you know what I mean because those are
in all four of those squads or
Conference Finals worthy you've got to
drop off from there Indiana's had a
great year but with the injuries you
know I think I give the kind of credit
for being so plucky and continuing to
win game but I think certainly in a
playoff atmosphere you know they're
gonna have a challenging time and you
saw that even with their loss against
the Warriors the other night just being
overmatched but it should be fun cuz I
don't know
I had no Waukee at the top of that total
poll for a while and the injuries to
them are tough Malcolm Brogdon goes down
Nikola Mirotic goes down and those guys
will be back in terms of you know either
early in the playoffs or at some point
but those are big blows and then Toronto
keeps rolling Philly's got a good thing
going I mean the way they put their
pieces together lately with with Jimmy
Butler closing games joelle being
dominant so it should be a good time he
said may make the athletic senior NBA
rider joining the Rich Eisen show and
you said the the word that always gets
me going me is of Northern California
boy as a warriors fan I know you wrote
about them and one of your latest pieces
how should we look at this Warriors team
you mentioned are they still the team to
be feared
they added boogie cousins you know it's
that point in a year right now where
they could care less where there
seated at or how they finish it's about
the playoffs for them but how do you see
this warriors dynasty after winning the
back-to-back championships how do you
see them as they approach the playoffs I
just think they're puzzling and
fascinating at the same time they're
they're playing at a fairly high level
but then they keep dropping games
occasionally that make you scratch your
head shouldn't be too shocking because
you know you mentioned to market it's
like that system I really made your
piece to integrate and continue to learn
about in terms of the context of the
talent they have a speaker system you
know and then you have different things
that are jammed about Kevin Durant being
out for a couple games with an ankle
demarcus getting a chance to shine
during that time they still have these
lapses about once a week and so like I
wrote about I don't think the
invincibility kind of perception is
there anymore Markieff Morris I love
talking to Markie Reserve
I mean shout out to the guys coming off
the bench who who just Debbie's he's
pretty real dude and he came strong with
his commentary you know and a lot of
times it's the guys that that are not as
high-profile that are willing to kind of
kind of give you the real and he said
flat out like I think they're more
beautiful with DeMarcus than they were
without and he talked about the personal
dynamics and the fact that outside
looking in for him you know a lot of
this stuff seems to be somewhat personal
somewhat real whether it's the dream on
kevin durant saga from however many
months ago you know the uncertainty of
kevin's free agency and and what that
does to kind of the mood in the room all
of those things for their rivals i think
represent some level of hope you know
some yesterday we had a poll question
I'm gonna presented to you again because
we heard the comments from Joelle and B
you know after the game yet that I'd say
I'm the most unstoppable player in the
NBA which we kind of laughed and even
are the people who answered on our poll
said he's probably the fifth or sixth
person but when you look at the most
unstoppable players right now in the NBA
we feel like LeBrons kind of taking a
backseat but who do you have as the most
unstoppable player right now in the NBA
III 20 I heard this discussion and and I
think Harden is the guy for me who I
think you know top of mind yep was who I
would go with and it's it's a
combination and you
talk about unstoppable I do think
traditionally we think about a big man
like Joe LM beat because you get that
ball and a little block and there's just
nothing you can do it's it's a little
bit like Shaq back in the day but with
James you're adding in the repertoire
with the step back which is just
impossible to defend I think it's
blocked this year but not very many
times but then you got the ability to
get to the line which is just an
absolute artist and I know it drives
people nuts but it is an artistry to get
to the line at the the rate that he does
and then it's you know we always seem to
skip over the fact that he's a finisher
one of the whether it's going to the rim
or you know pulling up from wherever he
gets that job done so I think James is
there you know Kevin Durant's right
there
you know Steph when he gets hot that's a
different style though you know that
probably my list Yanis is certainly in
the discussion you know that lack of
shooting is something where you can gain
the system a little bit to try to you
know get out Yanis a little bit but you
know the way he attacks that rim and
this the physicality of his game I think
he'd be there to just another minute
here with Sam amick he's the athletic
senior NBA rider here on the Rich Eisen
show Kirk Morrison filling in for Rich I
know that the NC double-a tournament is
going on and I'm we mentioned it they're
going to take the kind of the viewers
away from the NBA but some sneaky games
tonight
Oklahoma City traveling to Toronto San
Antonio taking on Houston but I'm here
in Los Angeles and the obviously the
conversation over the last couple of
days has been DeAngelo Russell returning
again to play against the Lakers and
look they CH Magic Johnson they traded
him away now I know they had to get out
of the Timofey Mozgov deal but you look
at where DeAngelo Russell is right now
and all start leading a team right now
currently in the playoffs are the Lakers
second-guessing possibly given up on a
guy like DeAngelo Russell because they
haven't got that return back from who
the point guard who they selected in
Lonzo ball I mean I guarantee if they
can wave a magic wand and have him be
part of this young core they would do
that in a heartbeat and and I think you
know at this point if they can just
flat-out swap D'Angelo for Londo they do
that too but yeah as you know because
you mentioned the Mozgov deal is tricky
in terms of like where you want to
blame because you know it's Mitch Mitch
Kupchak and Jim boss are the ones who
gave mosque off that ridiculous contract
and then at the time and I always I'm
kind of big on like we can't
retroactively Lee kind of take praise
back like I gave magic and Rob pálinka a
lot of credit for just getting off that
contract and it did come at a big cost
at the Angelo but that's one of the
moves that led them to getting LeBron so
you can get in the weeds a little bit on
that but the bottom line that's a dude
who who could he could be part of the
solution for them right now he's playing
at such a high clip 20 I was at that
Nets Kings game the other day and for
some insane reason decided to go home in
the mid third quarter so I missed his
twenty whatever place I know I know I
got a knack for it I don't know I
thought it was a rabbit I have to be
there then all of a sudden but he's he's
special man and and I gave him credit
cuz it's a heck of a recovery from the
days where all we were talking about
with him is snapchat and Nick Young and
yet a guy whose headlines were pretty
negative for a while yes you missed the
shot by rondae hollis-jefferson in the
shakes oh you missed all Sam appreciate
the time as always man oh you got a lot
to give too but thanks for stopping by
you got it because they appreciate that
Sam hey me the Athletics in the NBA
writer there the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience